president-elect Donald Trump will be
taken office immediately and then
heading off to vacation this weekend but
he's already got his eye on 20/20 in an
interview with The Washington Post Trump
said he's looking forward to trademark
his next campaign slogan which is not
gonna be da svidaniya American Cobra ads
in 2020 he plans to run with Keep
America great showing just how confident
he is that there will still be in
America in four years but people online
were quick to point out that they heard
that phrase somewhere before
oh yes keep America great was tagline
for the third summit of power but at
least he has a consistent vision for
this country so comedians that motto
might need to change
what's another movie-inspired slogan for
Trump's 2020 campaign Brian you want the
truth I can't handle the truth
all right good I'm just a girl standing
in front of a boy asking him to please
not get us in a war with China all right
points Judah Friedlander Toto we're not
in Kansas we're in Canada
[Applause]